now election day in california the
recall that's this coming tuesday and
democrats are desperate they are pulling
out every stop to try and save governor
gavin newsom from a massive political
upset now hollywood big tech major
unions along with oh let's see barack
obama kamala harris
even the imploding joe biden praised by
gavin newsom yeah they're begging the
people of california keep newsom in
office despite his massive failures he's
given checks to about two-thirds of the
people in
southern in all of california at the
time of a
recall election
timing is a little bit dubious to me
now biden will be in southern california
with newsome on monday and remember
newsom actually said he's so proud of
biden amid the afghanistan exit debacle
and the abandoning of americans take
that into account out on the west coast
and here's a question why hasn't there
been widespread condemnation of the
recent egg attack on larry elder in los
angeles which the la sheriff now says
looks like a hate crime now here's what
happened earlier this week take a look
[Music]
don't touch her okay
hey
hey michael stop
here with reaction california
gubernatorial candidate larry elder who
is now leading by double digits um
well they missed by a mile with the egg
um so that's good news you know did any
one of the people that took a swing at
i believe somebody that was part of your
security detail
did they get arrested did anyone get
arrested for the attempted assault on
you
not so far and as you pointed out the la
county sheriff said challenging the wolf
media if this had been
a d at the end of my name they'd be
calling it a hate crime and talking
about how this is an example of systemic
racism but sean this is the same kind of
media double standard i've been dealing
with ever since i've been running as you
know there was an allegation that larry
elder doesn't like women based on some
21 year old article i wrote where i was
quoting a left-wing
organization
and some allegation that i engaged in an
act of violence against a woman which i
vigorously denied but cnn politico and
the other outlets ran with that for days
and days and days there's just been an
allegation made by rose mcgowan rose
mcgowan is the actress who said her
career was destroyed because she refused
to sleep with harvey weinstein
it was because of rose that harvey
weinstein and because of other
allegations is facing a series of rape
charges now just yesterday rose mcgowan
said the wife of gavin newsom called her
on behalf of harvey weinstein's lawyer
and said to her six months before the
harvey weinstein story really blew up
can i how can we make you happy how can
this story go away and rose mcgowan even
produced emails from gavin newsom's wife
indicating that they had a
correspondence now i don't know whether
the story is true or false sean all i
know is if a an allegation was made that
my significant other on behalf of harvey
weinstein's lawyer called rose mcgowan
mcgowan and tried to get her to back off
the story that's all they'd be talking
about now politico has this story cnn
has this story we know they have the
story but they have not reported on it
at all real clear politics did newsmax
did i'm making the allegation here on
your program where's the investigation
where's the investigative journalist
where's journalism
yeah and we've seen the hypocrisy i mean
gavin newsom restaurants closing down
he's in restaurants no other californian
restaurants his kids in public school
his winery stays open
and now he's giving out checks we have
30 seconds how do you how do you time
the checks to what 60 is it is it 60
plus percent of californians just before
the recall isn't that true
uh yeah all of a sudden the new poll
comes out look the recall is within the
margin of error i'm asking people to
vote yes on the recall make sure you
sign your ballot if you don't trust the
the mail you can follow it online or you
can drop it off at a voting center and
then go to elected.com if you see
anything suspicious we have a battery of
lawyers ready to file lawsuits if
anything suspicious goes down so yes on
the recall and elect elder.com throw a
little something in the tip jar because
my opponent has raised 75 million
dollars so far sean would probably spend
about 100 million
it would be the biggest political
earthquake
in the modern time um
and i believe in miracles you know al
michaels do you believe in miracles i
actually do uh all right larry we're
wishing you a lot of luck we're watching
it very closely that's on this tuesday
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else